music Alright let's go, we're late, let's go, we've got to get to a um, this is Jason and over there is Will and the guy with the cap, Sean P. Hayes We've got some apps we've got to do an episode, let's do it in three, in two, this is SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess I was asking Sean if he, you know, because this is my guest
music 好的，我们走吧，我们迟到了，走吧，我们得去一个，嗯，这是杰森，那边是威尔，戴帽子的那个是肖恩·P·海耶斯 我们有些应用要做一期节目，我们用三声，两声开始，这是SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess SmartLess 我刚才问肖恩他，你知道的，因为这是我的嘉宾
and I was asking Sean what he did during the break because I was doing a little bit of homework, the tiny bit of homework that we do when it's your guest. Do you do a lot of work when it's your guest, Will? Sean, do you do a lot of work? I do, yeah, for sure. Yeah, for sure. Really? I do, I read about if there's an article, I'll watch something online that they've done.
然后我问肖恩他在休息期间做了什么，因为我做了一点点功课，就是当嘉宾是你的时我们做的那点微不足道的功课。威尔，当嘉宾是你的时，你会做很多功课吗？肖恩，你会做很多功课吗？我会的，是的，肯定的。是的，肯定的。真的吗？我会的，我如果有文章的话我会读一下，我会看一些他们在网上做过的事情。
Really? You'll watch an article, what channel is the article on? So, so then this is morning of or the week prior? Maybe a day before. What about you, Will? Let's take a couple weeks and I'll write it all out and then I kind of put it in my own words and I'll be like, I try to get inside the, I try to get inside the, I try to get inside the skin of the person who I got coming on, get inside their body and things like that.
真的吗？你会看一篇文章，那文章在哪个频道播？那么，那么这是在早上还是前一周？也许是前一天。你呢，威尔？花上几个星期，我把所有东西都写下来，然后我把它们变成我自己的话，我会觉得，我试着去融入，我试着去融入，我试着去融入那个要来的那个人的皮肤里，融入他们的身体之类的。
Do you love when it's not your guest and you can just show up late with your walk-up music and your lemon perfect and just get going? Like at basketball games? All right, that's enough. All right. Here we go. Where's my shitty intro? There it is.
当嘉宾不是你的时候，你可以伴着出场音乐、拿着你的柠檬无糖苏打水（Lemon Perfect）迟到并直接开始，你喜欢这样吗？就像在篮球比赛里那样？好了，够了。好了。我们开始吧。我的烂片头呢？在那儿呢。
All right. And this is, you know, you get a shitty intro because it's a shitty intro. And this is, you know, you get a shitty intro because it's a shitty guest. This is, we have big guests and we have small guests. This is a small one. All right. This fella hates coffee, likes cars, loves the Mets. I bet he hates the Yankees.
好了。这就是，你知道的，你得到一个烂片头因为这是一个烂片头。这就是，你知道的，你得到一个烂片头因为这是一个烂嘉宾。这就是，我们有大嘉宾，我们也有小嘉宾。这是一个小的。好啦。这家伙讨厌咖啡，喜欢车，爱极了纽约大都会队。我敢打赌他讨厌纽约扬基队。
He's probably our best, most famous stand-up comedian but doesn't curse. And if you haven't guessed who it is yet, how about he gave us the best sitcom the planet has ever had and they named it after him. Will and Sean, it's Jerry Seinfeld. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
他可能是我们最好、最著名的单口喜剧演员，但却不说脏话。如果你还没猜出他是谁的话，不如这样：他给我们带来了地球上有史以来最好的情景喜剧，而且他们还用他的名字给它命名。威尔和肖恩，他就是杰瑞·宋飞。是啊。是啊。是啊。是啊。
How about that? Oh my God. Guys, how do we book such big guests if there's something wrong? I don't know how we're doing it. Jerry, welcome to SmartList. I can't believe that you're here. I mean, you know, that you're doing this. I can't believe you said yes.
怎么样？哦，天哪。伙计们，如果我们出了什么问题，怎么能请到这么大牌的嘉宾？我不知道我们是怎么做到的。杰瑞，欢迎来到SmartList。真不敢相信你来了。我是说，你知道的，你居然在做这个。我真不敢相信你答应了。
I mean, things are slow on Long Island right now, maybe. I don't know what's going on. No, it just sounded like a fun show. Fun guys, bright guys, know the business, shorthand. Yeah, let's talk about the business tree as Will likes to call it. The business tree. Let's get inside baseball right away. Well, it's better than driving around and talking, right?
我是说，长岛现在可能有点萧条吧。我不知道发生了什么。不，只是听起来像个好玩的节目。有趣的家伙，聪明的家伙，懂这行，心有灵犀。是的，让我们来谈谈威尔喜欢叫的“商业树”。商业树。让我们马上切入正题。嗯，总比开车兜风聊天强，对吧？
I mean, you're not risking your life. That's so dangerous, Jerry. I wanted to say, what are you doing? What are you doing? It was a little dangerous. There was one really close call on a mountain road outside of Vegas. Really? Where I was just shooting Jerry Lewis's car.
我是说，你不会冒着生命危险。太危险了，杰瑞。我想说，你在干什么？你在干什么？这确实有点危险。在拉斯维加斯郊外的一条山路上，有一次差点就出事了。真的吗？当时我正开着杰瑞·刘易斯的车。
Oh my God. And it had no side view mirror. And I was a two-lane road and I went to make a left and someone was passing me in the opposing lane and didn't know, and I couldn't see them. And it was just a split second it would have all been over. Oh my God. Yeah, it was a little dangerous. It was a little dangerous.
哦，天哪。而且它没有后视镜。那是一条双向道路，我准备向左转，结果有人在对向车道超车却不知道，而我看不见他们。只要再过零界的一秒钟，一切就都结束了。哦，天哪。是的，这有点危险。这有点危险。
If you had perished in Jerry Lewis's car, I mean... Yeah, it's kind of a complete circle, right? I guess so. Oh my God. I suppose so. Jerry, let me just say this. I don't think we've met a number of times. We share a mutual friend in Chuck Martin.
如果你在杰瑞·刘易斯的车里丧命了，我是说……是的，这有点像一个完整的闭环，对吧？我想是的。哦，天哪。我想是的。杰瑞，我只想说这个。我觉得我们没有见过很多次面。我们和查克·马丁（Chuck Martin）有一个共同的朋友。
Oh yeah. Which is great. I love that. Oh yeah. I feel like the last time I saw you, Will, was at that hospital benefit in Toronto. In Toronto. And you came and did that very graciously. And it was the biggest fundraising night in Toronto history.
哦，是的。这太棒了。我喜欢那样。哦，是的。我觉得我上次见到你，威尔，是在多伦多的那场医院慈善义演上。在多伦多。你来了，而且非常慷慨地表演了。那是多伦多历史上规模最大的募款之夜。
Jerry came and did an hour. Wow. Yeah. Incredible. That was a few years ago. And we've done five since we got rock. Came and did the next one. Right.
杰瑞来表演了一个小时。哇。是的。太不可思议了。那是几年前的事了。自从我们……之后，我们已经办了五次了。接着又来了下一场。对的。
We've had gaff again. We had a bunch of people do it, but you kicked it off. And it was the single biggest night in Toronto. Oh, wow. Yeah, it was pretty cool. That was nice. So he's going to say this. I just want to say this before, because I've never said this to you before over all the
我们又请到了加夫（Gaff）。我们请了一堆人来演，但你是打头阵的。那是多伦多单场规模最大的一晚。哦，哇。是的，挺酷的。那很好。所以他要说这个。我只想在之前说这个，因为我在过去的所有
years. The first stand up show I ever went to was when you came and played Toronto. And I was such a fan. I used to watch you on Letterman. And my friends knew it for my 18th birthday. Because I don't know why I'd just never been to stand up. My friends surprised me and they bought me a ticket to see you downtown Toronto. It was such a thrill.
年里从来没对你说过。我看的第一场单口喜剧秀就是你来多伦多演出的时候。我是你的超级粉丝。我以前经常在莱特曼（Letterman）的节目里看你。我的朋友们在我18岁生日时知道了这件事。因为我不知道为什么我以前从来没去看过单口喜剧。我的朋友们给了我一个惊喜，他们买了一张票让我去多伦多市中心看你的演出。那真是太刺激了。
First ever. I remember that. It was like that really wooden kind of rock, it was like a rock, big rock club place. I can't remember the name of it. No, no, this place was, it was like the harbor front. Do you remember that? It was down by the water. No, you don't remember.
平生第一次。我记得。那就像是一个非常木质的那种摇滚，就像是一个摇滚大俱乐部的地方。我想不起来名字了。不，不，这个地方，就像是海滨。你还记得吗？就在水边。不，你不记得了。
You've only done 35 days. But Toronto is really one of the great jewels on the comedy tour. They love you in Toronto. I mean, Jerry did this night at this thing. It was like 5,000 people. You know, charity events can be pretty dry. You're absolutely destroyed. People still talk.
你只待了35天。但多伦多真的是喜剧巡演中一颗伟大的明珠。他们在多伦多非常喜欢你。我是说，杰瑞在这个活动上做过一晚。大概有5,000人。你知道，慈善活动有时会很枯燥。你简直大获成功。人们至今还在谈论。
My dad still talks about how. Wow. Yeah, we've had other ones. But the one that Jerry Seinfeld did was the best. How do you decide? You must get asked all the time, Jerry, to do stuff, to do charity stuff, to do appearances and things. It must be very hard to sort of, well, I guess hungry kids are important, but kids with cancer
我爸爸至今还在谈论那场演出有多……哇。是的，我们还办过其他的。但杰瑞·宋飞那场是最好的。你是怎么决定的？杰瑞，你一定经常被邀请去做各种事情，去做慈善活动、出场亮相之类的。要把这些分门别类一定很难，嗯，我猜挨饿的孩子很重要，但患癌症的孩子
is more important or less important. Like, how do you, I mean, it must be difficult. You just kind of, you set aside a certain number of shows every year that you're going to do, and I try and spread it around and just do different things each year. God, look how good you look. You know, I was doing a small bit of research. You guys, he's not 30 anymore. 67.
更重要还是不那么重要？我是说，这一定很难。你只是，你知道的，每年留出一定数量的演出要做，我试着把它们分散开来，每年做点不一样的。天哪，你看你看起来多好。你知道，我刚才做了一点点研究。你们知道的，他不再是30岁了。67岁了。
He looks. No way. Look at him. You look terrific. Thank you. Do you sleep in olive oil? Do you zip yourself into an olive oil ziplock? It's all moisturizer.
他看起来……不可能。看看他。你看上去棒极了。谢谢。你是在橄榄油里睡觉吗？你是把自己装进橄榄油的自封袋里吗？全靠保湿霜。
Is that right? Now, were you moisturizing well before Jessica came into your life? I know I wasn't before Amanda came into my life. I didn't know anything about facial toner. I didn't know anything about a separate soap for the face versus the body. Were you always good about taking care of yourself or did it take a very... I don't really do anything. Come on.
是吗？那么，在杰西卡（Jessica）走进你的生活之前，你很注重保湿吗？我知道在阿曼达（Amanda）走进我的生活之前我没有。我对面部爽肤水一无所知。我对洗脸和洗身体要用不同的肥皂一无所知。你以前就很擅长照顾自己，还是花了很长……我其实什么也没做。得了吧。
I do have a moisturizer. Sure. I remember in the 80s in New York, I think, and these gay guys look so good. What are they doing? Beautiful. And I went up to a counter in Bloomingdale's and I said, what do gay men use? Give me some of that. Yeah.
我确实有保湿霜。当然。我记得80年代在纽约，我想，那些同性恋小伙子看起来气色真好。他们在做什么？太漂亮了。我走到布鲁明代尔百货公司（Bloomingdale's）的一个柜台前说，同性恋男人用什么？给我来点那个。是的。
And they gave me a small jar. You splash water on your face in the morning. I do. I do that because Will told me to do that. And I do it every morning and still to this day, Will, I think of you every morning when I splash water on my face. Did you know that? That seems about right.
然后他们给了我一小罐。你早上会在脸上泼水。我确实会。我这么做是因为威尔叫我这么做的。我每天早上都这么做，直到今天，威尔，我每天早上在脸上泼水时都会想起你。你知道吗？听起来确实挺对的。
No, but cold water is the best thing you can do for you. Right. I remember from the Hustler, the Paul Newman Jackie Gleason movie. Remember that movie? Yes. And that's the break in the movie when Jackie Gleason is losing and he goes into the bathroom and he splashes water on his face and he kind of changes the moment. And I still do it.
不，冷水是对你能做的最好的事情。对。我从《江湖浪子》（The Hustler）这部保罗·纽曼（Paul Newman）和杰基·格里森（Jackie Gleason）的电影里记住了这一点。还记得那部电影吗？记得。那是电影里转折的时刻，当杰基·格里森快要输的时候，他走进洗手间，在脸上泼水，然后他某种程度上扭转了局面。我至今还在这样做。
I will do it in the middle of the day. If I just want to get out of one mood and try and get into a better mood, I will splash water on my face. Does it work? Yeah, it does. Every morning you do it still to transition from sleep, bed, bedroom, house into, here comes life, here comes the public. Yeah, it's a good transitional little cue for your body.
我会在大白天这么做。如果我只是想摆脱一种情绪，试着进入一种更好的情绪，我就会在脸上泼水。管用吗？是的，挺管用的。你每天早上依然这么做，为了从睡眠、床、卧室、房子过渡到，生活来了，公众来了。是的，这是给你身体的一个很好的过渡性小信号。
Also, change your shirt. Change your shirt. I see that. I do like a share costume change in the middle of the day. Sure. Don't go out in the pajamas. So now let me ask you something. When somebody asks you to do a charity event or a thing and they don't realize, I know
还有，换衬衫。换衬衫。我看到了。我确实会在大白天换演出服装。当然。别穿着睡衣出门。那现在我问你个问题。当有人请你去做一个慈善活动或类似的事情，而他们没有意识到，我知道
you have a banked, decades banked jokes and everything you could call upon, but you have to write something for a specific charity event. No. You don't do that because people have asked, I'm not a stand-up like you and who's brilliant like that, but people have asked me and I'm like, you don't understand. It's like asking a band to come play at a charity event. They already have their like list of songs they could just play. They know them.
你有一库存的、积累了数十年的笑话和你可以调用的所有东西，但你必须为一个特定的慈善活动写点东西。不。你不用那样做，因为人们问过，我不是像你那样才华横溢的单口喜剧演员，但人们问过我，我说，你不懂。这就像是要求一支乐队来慈善活动演出。他们已经有了现成的歌单可以直接演奏。他们懂这些。
But when you have to do a specific event and write specifically for that, it's a lot of work, right? Oh, it's impossible. The only person I know that does that consistently is Colin Quinn. Oh, really? Colin Quinn will write for a week when he has to do like a weird guest set or someplace and he'll write about the company, which just blows my mind. What about this?
但当你必须做一场特定的演出并专门为此创作时，那工作量很大，对吧？哦，那是不可能的。我所知道的唯一一个能始终如一做到这一点的人是科林·奎恩（Colin Quinn）。哦，真的吗？科林·奎恩当他必须做一些奇怪的嘉宾拼盘或去某个地方时，他会写上整整一周，他会写关于那个公司的段子，这简直让我大开眼界。那这个呢？
What about acceptance speeches? When you're nominated for something, do you grind over what you may or may not say or do you like to use like off the cuff? I like to write something. I like to have something. I get irritated when people go. I'm completely surprised. No, you can't be.
获奖感言呢？当你获得某项提名时，你会为自己可能说或不说的话绞尽脑汁，还是喜欢临场发挥？我喜欢写点东西。我喜欢有所准备。当人们说：我完全惊呆了。不，你不可能。
There's only five people left. You can't be that surprised. This has been publicized. You got dressed in a tuxedo. Now, what do you do? Are the unused acceptance speeches somewhere in your files? He's never lost. No.
只剩下五个人了。你不可能那么震惊。这已经是公开的了。你都穿好燕尾服了。那么，你都做什么？那些没用上的获奖感言都放在你档案里的某个地方吗？他从来没输过。不。
Guess what? You want to know what's shocking? He has a lot. Am I right here? Is there one Emmy for Seinfeld as best show that you never won for lead? That's correct. Correct again. Even though we had 68 other Emmys that the show won, but the show as a show only won one.
你猜怎么着？你想知道什么最令人震惊吗？他有很多。我没说错吧？《宋飞传》作为最佳剧集有没有一次没赢得最佳主角的艾美奖？没错。又答对了。尽管我们有其他68个该剧赢得的艾美奖，但该剧作为一个整体只赢得了一个。
And writing, I bet a bunch. What made that okay? Was it the money? Yeah. Yeah. No, it was really the, we weren't LA enough for that crowd. We were really, it was really a New York kind of attitude. You know what, Jerry?
至于编剧，我敢说有一大堆。是什么让这一切变得可以接受？是因为钱吗？是啊。是啊。不，真的在于，我们对那群人来说不够好莱坞化。我们真的，那真是一种纽约式的态度。你知道吗，杰瑞？
I tell you, this is a true story. So yesterday, we were, or two days ago, we were doing, the three of us were doing a little business zoom. And I was up in my sort of new office upstairs and I had a bunch of, the guys were giving me, because I had a bunch of critics choice awards lined up on the shelf. I did not put them there. Not a bunch. It wasn't a bunch. There were six.
我告诉你，这是一个真实的故事。所以昨天，我们，或者两天前，我们在做，我们三个在开一个小型的商业Zoom会议。我当时在楼上我那个算是新办公室的地方，我有一堆，那几个家伙在逗我，因为我的书架上排了一堆评论家选择奖（Critics Choice Awards）的奖杯。不是我摆在那儿的。不是一堆。不是一堆。有六个。
And they had been unpacked by somebody else. And they were on the shelf. I had not organized it that way, right? Right. So they started giving me help. And I said, these are critics choice. I said, they're not your Emmys. They're not your inside show biz people who go like, oh, I'm friends with Bateman.
而且它们是别人拆开包装的。它们就在书架上。我可不是那样整理的，对吧？对。所以他们开始帮我出谋划策。我说，这些是评论家选择奖。我说，它们不是你们的艾美奖。它们不是你们圈内那些会说“哦，我和贝特曼（Bateman）是朋友”的电视圈内人。
So I'm going to vote for him, whatever. These were the critics. This is who the top critics decided was the best. Are they smarter? Are they better? Do their decisions mean more? They're just, they're not as inside. They don't, they don't like go eat at the counter downstairs at the Beverly Hills hotel with Jason on a 2K11.
所以我打算投票给他，诸如此类。这些是评论家。这是顶级评论家们决定的最佳人选。他们更聪明吗？他们更好吗？他们的决定更有意义吗？他们只是，他们没那么圈子化。他们不会，他们不会像杰森那样在2011年去贝弗利山酒店楼下的柜台吃东西。
That's a fair point. You know what I mean? Right. Right. I just won one of those. And I thought it was nice. It means a lot more. Yeah.
这倒是个公平的观点。你知道我的意思吗？对的。对的。我刚刚赢得了其中一个。我觉得挺不错的。意义重大得多。是啊。
You should be very proud of yourself. Yeah. Okay. Where did the love for the Mets start? What is the current temperature on your love for the Mets? And having to also, do you hang out with Keith Hernandez? I started, I grew up on Long Island. So, and the Yankees, I, you know, I think these kinds of things are very instinctual.
你应该为自己感到非常骄傲。是啊。好了，对大都会队（Mets）的热爱是从哪里开始的？你目前对大都会队的热爱程度如何？而且还得，你跟基思·赫南德兹（Keith Hernandez）一起混吗？我开始，我在长岛长大。所以，对于扬基队，我，你知道的，我觉得这种事情是非常本能的。
And the Mets were kind of, they weren't good, but they were funny and weird and different. And it just, it just fit me better. And now I'm, when I go there and my wife goes with me and I go, you see these losers? I go, this is, this is me. This is who I really am. Look at Gary Carter. Yeah. Now, do you, you hang out with Gary at all and Keith?
而大都会队算是，他们虽然不厉害，但他们很有趣、很古怪、很与众不同。这，这更适合我。现在我是，当我去那儿时，我妻子陪着我，我说：你们看到这些失败者了吗？我说，这就是，这就是我。这才是真正的我。看看加里·卡特（Gary Carter）。对啊。那么，你，你跟加里和基思一起混吗？
No. Well, you didn't. Well, Gary's no longer with us, but thank you for asking. Thank you. And Keith, I saw a couple of weeks ago, I went, I go in the booth sometimes when I go to the games. I like to help announce that's fun. And, but no, I don't really socialize that much. Would you could, if you, would you ever entertain doing play by play for the Mets as a steady career?
不。好吧，你没有。好吧，加里已经不在我们身边了，但谢谢你问。谢谢。至于基思，我几周前见过。我去球场时有时会去解说室。我喜欢帮忙播报，那挺有意思的。不过，不，我其实不怎么社交。如果可以的话，你会不会考虑把棒球比赛实况转播作为大都会队的一项稳定职业？
If you, if you, if you could stay at your house as, as I guess they're doing it now, they're not really traveling with the teams. Would you, would you ever consider doing play by play for the Mets for a year? Let's say a full season. Um, no, wouldn't that be fun? No, it would be fun. Yes, it would be fun, but you're not interested. I'm very dedicated to, to my, my little craft of a standup. I love to, uh, and I still find it challenging and I still like to, um, I'm not doing it right now.
如果你，如果你，如果你能待在家里，正如我猜他们现在所做的那样，他们其实并不随球队到处旅行。你会不会考虑为大都会队做一整年的实况转播？比如说一个完整的赛季。嗯，不会，那不是很有趣吗？不，那会很有趣。是的，那会很有趣，但你没兴趣。我非常致力于，致力于我的，我的单口喜剧小手艺。我喜欢，呃，我仍然觉得它很有挑战性，而且我依然喜欢，呃，我虽然现在没在做。
But normally when I'm in, in the city, I'm like, I'm trying to work on a piece of material and then I go out to the club that night and try and make it work. And that just, that, that's my, my habit trail. How often would you want to come up with new, a new set? Um, a new. I don't really care about the, the set. It's just like, I've got three new ideas or I'm trying to get this to work and it just turns over organically. The younger guys do this. This is my new hour thing.
但通常当我在，在城里时，我就像，我正试图创作一段段子，然后我那天晚上去俱乐部试着把它弄好。而那，那就是，我的，我的习惯路线。你多久想出一个新的，一套新段子？嗯，一套新的。我其实并不在意什么“一套”。这就像是，我有三个新点子，或者我正试图把这个弄好，然后它就会有机地更新换代。年轻的小伙子们会这样做。这就是我的新一小时专场。
You know, and I always say, dude, I didn't see your old hour. Right. Yeah. Right. So you're, you're just adding a joke a day, a joke a week or whatever. I just do whatever, uh, whatever's, you know, it's like, uh, it's, it's like, uh, a supermarket. I just go, I won't take that one down. You know, it's just like, I have the, I like to have the whole thing in my head and then I just make it up as I'm on stage.
你知道的，我总是说，老兄，我都没看过你的旧一小时专场。对。是啊。对。所以你，你只是每天加一个笑话，每周加一个笑话，诸如此类。我只是做任何，任何，你知道的，这就像，呃，这就像，呃，一家超市。我只是去，我不会把那个拿下来。你知道的，这就像，我喜欢把所有东西都装在脑子里，然后在舞台上现挂。
Do you, you have a memory of writing, and you probably even asked this million times. So I'm sorry if I'm boring, but do you remember writing your first joke? Do you remember? I do. Yeah. I do. Cause that's what made me do it. I wrote this joke and I told some guys in college, it was my bit about being left handed as always associated with negative things to left feet, left handed compliments.
你，你还记得写第一个笑话的记忆吗，你可能已经被问过一百万次了。所以我很抱歉如果我很无聊，但你还记得写第一个笑话吗？你记得吗？我记得。是的。我记得。因为那就是让我从事这个的原因。我写了这个笑话，我在大学里讲给几个家伙听，这是我关于左撇子总是和消极事物联系在一起的段子，比如左脚、言不由衷的赞美。
You go to a party. There's nobody there. Would everybody go? They left. And that was the first joke I ever wrote. Still funny. And these guys, they left and I was stunned. I was shocked.
你去参加一个派对。那里一个人也没有。大家都会说什么？他们“离开（left）”了。那是写出来的第一个笑话。依然很好笑。那些家伙，他们离开了，我惊呆了。我震惊了。
I mean, I really never thought I could be a comedian. But when you were in high school, so you write that joke and they laugh and you say you never thought you could be. Was it something that you did wish you could be when you were younger? Yeah. Yeah. But it was like wishing to be an astronaut or a baseball player. You can't do that. Real people can't do that.
我是说，我真的从没想过自己能成为一名喜剧演员。但当你还在高中时，你写了那个笑话，他们笑了，你说你从没想过你能成为……这真的是你年轻时希望自己能成为的吗？是的。是的。但这就像幻想着成为一名宇航员或棒球运动员。你做不到那种事。正常人做不到那种事。
I didn't even know what they were doing. I didn't understand how do they talk in a series of jokes. I thought maybe they're just like that all the time. I thought they were geniuses. How long did it take you to learn how to craft the joke and not be like, well, I'll just go up there and talk. One set. One set. I did one set and it was a total disaster.
我甚至不知道他们在做什么。我不理解他们怎么能用一系列笑话进行对话。我以为也许他们一直都是那样的。我以为他们是天才。你花了多长时间才学会如何精心创作一个笑话，而不是像“好吧，我就上台去随便聊聊”？一场演出。一场演出。我做了一场演出，结果简直是一场灾难。
And I realized, oh, you got to have this all figured out in advance. Right. But you know, the comedians that are as skilled and as pedigreed as you, you hear about them actually looking to bomb sometimes. Or they enjoy the discomfort of having it not be super smooth all the time. Is that true? If so, do you have any of that? I don't think it's true and I wouldn't have no interest in that. That sounds like they're hedging their bets.
然后我意识到，哦，你必须提前把这一切都想清楚。对。但你知道的，像你这样技艺精湛、资历深厚的喜剧演员，你听说他们有时其实是在寻求搞砸。或者他们享受那种事情并不总是超级顺利带来的不适感。这是真的吗？如果是的话，你身上有这种倾向吗？我不觉得这是真的，我对那毫无兴趣。听起来他们是在给自己留退路。
Right. That sounds like something that Galfinakis says when he has a bad joke. I mean, everybody works completely differently, I find. Yeah. They have their own way of doing it. When you try this new material out there, when you said you had like three new things you want to try out or something, and you walk into a comedy club. I mean, these other young comics have to be blown away that you're fucking, oh my God.
对。听起来像是加利费安纳基斯（Galifianakis）在讲了一个烂笑话时会说的话。我是说，我发现每个人完全都是以不同的方式在工作。是的。他们有自己的一套方法。当你把这些新段子拿到外面去试，当你刚才说你有三个想尝试的新东西或者别的什么，然后你走进一家喜剧俱乐部。我是说，这些年轻的喜剧演员看到你他妈的来，天哪，一定惊呆了吧。
Yes, sir. Right this way, sir. Yes, the floor is yours. I mean, it must be mind blowing for them. But when I was starting out, Rodney would come in and David Brenner would come in and we would just, people would be getting ready to go on stage and they would just grab your sleeve and say, no, Rodney just walked in and then you would stand in the back and you would watch him. And that was an amazing experience for us when we were kids.
是的，先生。这边请，先生。是的，舞台是您的。我是说，对他们来说这一定太震撼了。但当我刚出道时，罗德尼（Rodney）会进来，大卫·布伦纳（David Brenner）会进来，我们当时，大家正准备上台，他们就会抓住你的袖子说：“不，罗德尼刚刚进来了”，然后你就站在后台看着他。对我们这些年轻人来说，那是一次了不起的体验。
And so I think they think it's weird. They don't understand why I'm there, why I would be doing this. They think you're big timing it a little bit, do you think? No, I think they think, but you already have money. Why are you even bothering with this? Right, right. That's what they think. And I guess that makes some kind of sense, but I don't really.
所以我认为他们会觉得这很诡异。他们不明白我为什么会在那儿，我为什么要做这个。你觉得他们会觉得你有点在摆大牌吗？不，我觉得他们在想，但你已经有钱了。你为什么还要折腾这个？对，对。他们是这么想的。我想这在某种程度上也说得通，但我真的……
It'd be like going to mass and you're like, you know, the regular priest is there and all of a sudden the pope walks in and they're like, sorry, man, you're out. The pope's here. You know, working out a joke. I don't want to, I'm not standing in front of 3000 people that paid money and doing a joke that I have no idea if there's anything there. I can't do that. Was it a comfortable experience for you that you writing a joke, let's say for Julia Louis-Dreyfus, you would hope that she would be able to do, but you don't know.
这就好比你去望弥撒，你知道的，常规的神父在那儿，突然教皇走了进来，然后他们说：“抱歉，老兄，你得退下了。教皇来了。”在打磨一个笑话。我不想，我不是站在3000个付了钱的人面前，去讲一个我完全不知道里面有没有料的笑话。我做不到。对你来说，创作一个笑话是一次舒适的体验吗，比如说为朱莉娅·路易斯-德利法斯（Julia Louis-Dreyfus）写，你会希望她能演出来，但你并不知道。
In other words, writing for actors as opposed to. Right. Well, that we learned as we were doing it. Larry and I had never written anything for anyone but ourselves. We had never written dialogue and we just kind of made it up as we went along. But getting to know the actors and living there with them, that is an unbelievable secret weapon. You know, you're on the set all day with people and then when I go back to the writer's room, I would say, Michael has this funny thing he does.
换句话说，为演员写剧本而不是……对。好吧，那是我们在边做边学的。我和拉里（Larry）以前从没为除了我们自己以外的任何人写过东西。我们从没写过对话，我们只是边走边编。但了解演员并和他们生活在一起，那是一个令人难以置信的秘密武器。你知道的，你一整天都和人们在片场，然后当我回到编剧室时，我会说：“迈克尔（Michael）有个很好笑的习惯动作。我们把它加进去吧。”对，对。宋飞传，好吧，你写试播集时还不叫这个名字。当时叫《宋飞传记》（The Seinfeld Chronicles），是这样吗？是的，《宋飞传记》。那是你写过的第一个剧本吗？是的。是的。
Let's put this in. Right, right. Was Seinfeld, well, it wasn't called that when you wrote the pilot. It was called the Seinfeld Chronicles, is that right? Yeah, the Seinfeld Chronicles. Was that the first script you'd ever written? Yes. Yes.
哇，太疯狂了。这不公平。挺公平的。公平。等等，但这太疯狂了，因为你和拉里·大卫（Larry David），我是说，我不认识你，很高兴认识你，我是你的超级大粉丝。我也是，肖恩。但你们俩似乎有着如此相似的幽默感。这两个家伙碰在一起的几率有多大？
Wow, that's crazy. That's unfair. That's fair. It's fair. Wait, but it's so crazy because you and Larry David, I mean, I don't know you and it's a pleasure to meet you and I'm a huge fan. Same here, Sean. But you guys seem to have such similar senses of humor. What are the odds of these two guys?
哦，这就是为什么我请他和虫我一起做，因为我会在俱乐部的酒吧里偶遇他，我们会聊上五分钟，而且总是爆笑。是的。当我得到这个机会时，我想让这部剧听起来就像我和拉里的对话。所以我说，你愿意和我一起写这部剧吗？我觉得我们聊天时很有趣。是的，非常……肖恩，你怎么看？
Well, that's why I asked him to do it with me because I would bump into him in the bar at the clubs and we'd talk for five minutes and it was always hilarious. Yeah. And when I got this opportunity, I thought I want the show to sound like me and Larry talking. So I said, would you write this show with me? I think when we talk, it's funny. Yeah, it's very... Sean, what do you think?
你们是在地铁上认识的？不，不，不。是一起拿着剧本吗？我只是说，很多时候才华横溢的人会和编剧碰头，但双方的声音并不契合。你知道的，当节目行不通时。但拉里，我是说，是的，拉里在纽约做了很多年单口喜剧。我认识一堆以前就认识他的人。吉米·瓦利（Jimmy Valli）以前总是谈起早年间的拉里。
You met him on the subway? No, no, no. With the script together? I'm just saying, a lot of the times talent will meet up with the writer, but the voices don't connect. You know, when the show doesn't work. But Larry, I mean, yeah, Larry was a stand-up for many years in New York. I know a bunch of people who know him from back in the day. Jimmy Valli used to always talk about Larry from back in the day.
是的。我是说，那是一个伟大的……该剧的另一个秘密武器是我雇用了能与我产生共鸣的人。对。所以我不想作为演员去勉强自己。我知道那样行不通。所以让我试着营造一个对我来说感觉比较正常的环境。而那三个人是我一见面就喜欢的人。
Yeah. I mean, that was a great... Another secret weapon of the show is I hired people that I could connect with. Right. So I didn't want to stretch myself as an actor. I knew that wouldn't work. So let me just try and create an environment that feels kind of normal to me. And those three people are people that I loved when I met them.
而且，你知道的，你只是……我不知道那是……还是只是瞎猫碰死耗子。是的。但我就是和他们有共鸣。我其实并没有在演戏，你知道的，就像，这就是我会跟这种类型的家伙说话的方式。对，对，对。我们马上回来。
And, you know, you just... I don't know if that was... Or just lucky guesses. Yeah. But I just connected with them. I wasn't really acting, you know, just like, this is how I would talk to this type of guy. Right, right, right. We'll be right back.
现在，回到节目中。我喜欢那种随性轻松的感觉，没有人……看起来像是在刻意讨笑。你只是在享受这些人，享受这些台词。是的。而且只是……太自然了。你们从来没有强求过。
And now, back to the show. I loved how casual and easy it was and no one was trying... Never really looked like you were asking for a laugh. You were just enjoying these people and enjoying these words. Yes. And it was just... It was so unforced. You guys never pressed.
好吧，还有一件事，很多……很多节目，这将会是……这可能会引发争议。哦，糟糕。很多情景喜剧。发生的情况是，它们开始时可能有一个有趣的设定或者一些有趣的东西，但接着它们深入到角色中，然后就变成了……它们总是试图那样做。
Well, here's the other thing that a lot of... A lot of shows, this is going to... This is controversial, potentially. Uh-oh. A lot of sitcoms. What happens is they start to maybe have a funny premise or they have some funny stuff, but then they get into the characters and then it becomes about... They always try to do that.
从来没有什么“非常特别的宋飞”。对。它总是……你总是专注于笑话。你总是专注于让它尽可能好笑。就是这样。就是这样。这就是你与观众达成的协议。
There was never then on a very special Seinfeld. Right. It was... You were always about the jokes. You were always about making it as funny as possible. That's it. That's it. And that was the agreement that you had with your audience.
顺便说一句，“就是这样”这句说得太棒了。这就是那个协议。我打开电视是因为我想在那一刻看到最搞笑的节目。因为这也符合单口喜剧演员的风格，对吧？那是该剧早期的模式，对吧？你在舞台上。你基本上会做一段半成品的演出。然后你进入杰瑞的生活，看看那些事情是真实发生的
By the way, it's a great that's it. That was the agreement. And I turned it on because I wanted to see the funniest possible show in that moment. Because that's consistent with a stand-up too, right? That was the early format of the show, right? You were on stage. You would be doing sort of like a semi-set. And then you'd go into Jerry's life and where that stuff was actually happening
还是你看到了它的起源。我们基本上就是这样把它卖给NBC的。我喜欢那样。你会看到一个喜剧演员是如何获得他的素材的。我知道我们其实永远无法真正做到这一点。我们在前几集里有点强行为之，但后来我们不得不放弃了。不过那挺酷的。现在，你觉得如今情景喜剧的现状怎么样？
or you saw the genesis. That was kind of how we sold it to NBC. I like that. You'll see how a comedian gets his material. I knew we were never really going to be able to do that. And we kind of forced it for a few episodes, but then we had to abandon it. It was pretty cool though. Now, what do you think about the health of the sitcom nowadays?
我是说，肖恩，如果我错了请纠正我，威尔和格瑞丝（Will and Grace）甚至在同一天晚上播出，对吧？我是说，当时有那么多情景喜剧。我想我们开播的第一年是你们的最后一年。哦，真的吗？98年？我想是的。98年，是的。但以前播出的有那么多，现在大概只有半打左右。
I mean, Sean, correct me if I'm wrong, wasn't Will and Grace on the same night even? I mean, there were so many sitcoms. I think our first year was your last year. Oh, really? 98? I think so. 98, yeah. But there used to be so many on the air and now there's like a half dozen.
你跟我一样，会怀念它们吗？你觉得它们还会回归吗？比如我在想，那群人去哪儿了？为什么人们还是不想要那种东西？我不明白。我觉得它变得太像一个雷区了，尤其是在传统的电视网层级中，我们担心这些人，我们担心那个，然后我们把所有的笑话都删掉了，最后你看的就是剩下的那些。
Do you, like me, miss them? And do you ever see them coming back? Like, I wonder, like, where's that audience? Why don't people still want that? I don't get it. I think it's become too much of a minefield, especially in a traditional network hierarchy of, we're worried about these people, we're worried about this, and then we take all the jokes out and then what you see is what's left.
我觉得这很准确。它只是变得，太谨小慎微了，你知道的，而谨小慎微的喜剧效果并不那么好。很多取得过你那种成功的人，那种巨大且无人能及的成功，他们花了很多生命中的时间去追逐那种东西。好吧，我得做点一样好甚至更好的东西，有那么多人在这样做。你看起来像，是的，不，我很好。那就行了。我完全没问题。
I think that's correct. It's just become, it's too careful, you know, and careful comedy doesn't work that great. A lot of people that have had your success and it was and still is just massive and unmatched, they spend a lot of their lives chasing that kind of thing. Well, I got to do something as good or better as, and so many people do that. You seem like, yeah, no, I'm good. That was it. I'm totally fine.
好吧，不管是谁想的，我从没想过我会做出那样的事。对。当我们在做这部剧时，我以为这有机会成为一个小众的东西，可能会在某个冷门的时段存活下来，也许我们可以那样活下去。当这部剧成为一个巨大的热播剧时，对我来说完全是个震惊。对，但我的意思是，你没有渴望再去拍一部有剧本的电视剧，对吧？对。还是说你有？
Well, I, whoever thought, I never thought I would do anything like that. Right. When I, when we were doing the show, I thought this has a chance to maybe be a little niche thing that might survive on a obscure time slot somewhere and maybe we can survive like that. When the show became a big hit, it was a complete shock to me. Right, but my point of saying that is you have no desire to go do another scripted TV show, right? Right. Or do you?
不，我没有。我拿到了每个人都梦寐以求的通行证，你可以做你想做的事。对。而且公众也很欣赏这一点，因为有些人你取得了成功，但那并不是你真正想做的事，或者你做了别人想做的事然后取得了成功。但我拿到了这张通行证，我知道我拿到了。对。所以我感觉很舒适。
No, I don't. I got the ride that everybody wants where you get to do what you want. Right. And the public also appreciates it because some people you have success, but it's not really what I want to do or you do what somebody else wants to do and you have success. But I got the ride and I knew I got the ride. Right. And so I just felt comfortable.
但你并不期待去拍一部情景喜剧。你很乐意做一名单口喜剧演员。不。人生计划，人生计划是什么？是，是成为一名成功的单口喜剧演员吗？是的。我是说，如果你能做到的话，那听我对这感到非常满意。
But you weren't looking to do a sitcom. You were happy being a stand-up. No. The life plan, what was the life plan? Was it, was it to be a successful stand-up? Yeah. I mean, that seemed like a pretty good life if you could pull that off. I was very happy with that.
哇。是的，然后现在你得以某种程度上回过头去，你实际上两者兼得了。你去了，你做了那个。现在你来到了这个地方，你可以专注于你最喜欢做的事情。是的。但后来我拍了一部电影。对。
Wow. Yeah. And then now you get to kind of go back and you actually get to have both. You went and you did that. And now you're in this place where you get to focus on the thing that you like to do the most. Yeah. But then I ended up doing a movie. Right.
我在病毒流行期间，我的一个编剧在看我关于蛋挞（Pop-Tart）的单口喜剧段子。他说，我们应该拍一部关于蛋挞的电影。五年里，每当他这么说时我都只是嘲笑他。然后他说：“让我和我们俩都喜欢的另一个编剧开一次会。”我说：“好吧，我给你开一次Zoom会议。”然后我们开始讨论这个。我们开始讨论正确的素材。如果我们把它拍成像《太空先锋》（The Right Stuff）那样会怎么样？
I, during the virus, one of my writers was looking at one of my stand-up bits about the Pop-Tart. And he said, we should do a movie about the Pop-Tart. And I, for five years, I thought, I just laughed at him when he would say that. And then he said, give me one meeting with this other writer that we both liked. And I said, okay, I'll give you one Zoom meeting. And we started talking about it. And we started talking about the right stuff. And what if we did it like the right stuff?
你知道的，1964年的家乐氏（Kellogg's）对阵Post（波斯特），就像美国对阵苏联。我开始笑了。接下来的事我们都知道了，我们写了这部电影，现在我们正在拍摄它。少来。不可能。你在里面演？我在里面演。是的。
You know, Kellogg's versus Post in 1964, like the U.S. versus Russia. And I started laughing. And the next thing we knew, we wrote this movie and now we're shooting it. Come on. No way. You're in it? And I'm in it. Yeah.
而且我是导演。等一下。这太不可思议了。我们现在是在爆猛料吗？还是我们一直躲在山洞里没读过关于它的新闻？这只是一个小小的简讯，你知道的，不过，是的，我们宣布了。这就是这一集的主旨，杰森。这就是你在质问我们到底有没有对嘉宾做任何研究的那一集。
And I'm directing it. Wait a minute. That's incredible. Are we making news right now? Or have we just been in a hole and haven't read about it? It was a quick blurb, you know, but it's, yeah, we announced it. This is the episode, Jason. This is the episode where you're asking whether or not we do any research on our guest.
而你居然错过了杰瑞在导演这部像巨作一样的东西的事。难道不挺迷人的吗，我居然什么都不知道？不，这不迷人。这很尴尬。所以当我把蛋挞的段子写进我的单口喜剧时，家乐氏很喜欢。所以他们做了这个蛋挞。这是最初的蛋挞盒子。那是我大概六岁时的照片。
And you missed that Jerry's directing this, like this huge thing. Isn't it charming, though, that I just don't know anything? No, it's not charming. It's embarrassing. So when I did the Pop-Tart bit of my stand-up, so Kellogg's liked it. So they made this Pop-Tart. This is the original Pop-Tart box. And that's me at like six.
不会吧。不会吧。他们把那张照片印在盒子上。听众朋友们，我们有一张年轻的杰瑞在蛋挞盒子上的照片。电影是怎样的？给我们讲讲这部电影吧。这部电影叫《无霜的面包》（Unfrosted）。他们开始做无霜的了吗？
No way. No way. And they put that on the box. Listener, we have a picture of young Jerry on the box of Pop-Tart. And what's the movie? Tell us about the movie. The movie's called Unfrosted. Did they start Unfrosted?
他们确实做了。最初的那些是无霜的，正如你所看到的。就是那个。是的。但我们并没有美化这个故事。哦，天哪。太棒了。但其中有几个元素是真实的。
They did. The first ones were Unfrosted, as you can see. There it is. Yeah. But we're not sugarcoating this story. Oh, boy. Wonderful. But there are several elements of it that are true.
那是……我不想用……请讲，我们有时间。不是谁都能拍电影，但……你给我们讲讲你的创意。给我们讲讲你的创意。好吧，真实的故事是这样的。
It was... I don't want to bore you with... Please, we've got time. Not anybody's movie, but... You pitch us. You pitch us right now. Okay. So here's the real story.
Post想出了这个点子。家乐氏在它问世前一两个月听说了这件事。他们吓坏了，说：“Post要推出这种烤面包糕点。我们得想出点什么来。”所以这是真实的故事。然后他们真的做到了。他们想出了一个滑稽的名字，叫“蛋挞（Pop-Tart）”。
Post came up with this idea. Kellogg's hears about it a month or two before it's going to come out. And they freak out and they go, Post is coming out with this toaster pastry. We've got to come up with something. And so that's the true story. And then they did. And they came up with this funny name, Pop-Tart.
所以蛋挞大获成功。而Post的产品砸了。所以……那叫什么名字？它叫“乡村广场（The Country Square）”。少来。那是肖恩的绰号。那是肖恩的绰号。
And so Pop-Tart was a huge smash. And the Post product was a bomb. And so... What was it called? It was called The Country Square. Come on. That's Sean's nickname. That's Sean's nickname.
对，那是我的绰号。玛乔丽·波斯特（Marjorie Post），Post公司的负责人，她住在海湖庄园（Mar-a-Lago），她就是建造那个庄园的人。什么？她建造了那个庄园。那是她住过的地方。真长见识，先生。
Yeah, that's my nickname. And Marjorie Post, who was the head of Post, who lived in Mar-a-Lago, she's the one who built that estate. What? She built that estate. That's where she lived. It's helpful, sir.
所以这就是我们开始的地方。然后我们发明了一堆疯狂的……我们把家乐氏变成了一个电影制片厂，托尼虎（Tony the Tiger）甚至在里面，你知道的，在小卖部里。正为他的合同发愁呢。这太荒谬了。这几乎有点像《疯狂世界》（It's a Mad, Mad, Mad, Mad World）类型的喜剧。我喜欢。
And so that's kind of where we started. And then we invented a bunch of insane... We turned Kellogg's into kind of a movie studio, where Tony the Tiger is, you know, as a commissary. Just off about his deal. It's very silly. It's almost kind of mad, mad world type comedy. I love that.
我们能谈谈你和这位伟大的女性美满的婚姻吗？我只见过她一次。她很喜欢你。但她看起来非常活泼。就像她是你的一个好哥们儿一样。这就是你们能成为如此要好的死党的秘诀吗？我妻子说，当一对夫妇说“他是我的最好朋友”或“她是我的最好朋友”时，
Can we talk about your great marriage to this great woman? I've met her only once. She loves you. But she seems very effervescent. Like she's like this great pal of yours. Is that the secret that you guys are just such good buddies? My wife says when a couple says he's my best friend or she's my best friend,
那段婚姻就差不多到头了。对。我妻子不是“最好朋友”的粉丝。然而，然而……然而。你娶了一个哥们儿，对吧？你没娶个媳妇。不，不。
that's the end of that marriage. Right. My wife is not a fan of best friends. However, however... However. You have married a buddy, correct? You haven't married a wife. No, no.
不，我娶了一个长岛犹太女孩，因为我想，这会给我某种优势，也许能让我做到这一点，让我能做到这些。这对你的皮肤也很好。对。看看你的皮肤。但她非常……她很搞笑，而且，你知道的，有时很难对付。
No, I married a Long Island Jewish girl because I thought, well, that would give me some kind of advantage to maybe do this, be able to do this. It'd be great for your skin, too. Yeah. Look at your skin. But she's very... She's funny and she's, you know, a difficult at times.
我总觉得最痛苦的事情是无聊。对，没错。而她一点也不无聊。所以她从来不无聊，我热爱跟她结婚。今年夏天我们想你了，因为我们有……我让这两家伙去了长岛，就在你们附近。有一次，我们得……下次他们来的时候，我们得聚一聚，杰瑞。
And I kind of feel like the most painful thing is boredom. Yeah, right. And she's not boring. And so she was never boring and I love being married to her. We missed you this summer because we had... I had both these guys out in Long Island and out near you guys. And at one time, we got... Next time they come out, we got to get together, Chair.
哦，太棒了。他在躲我们呢。我刚才没听清你说话。现在，她会向你妥协吗？你的孩子们会向你妥协吗？他们觉得你在做的事是在浪费时间，还是觉得你真的很擅长你做的事？他们不……他们觉得这没什么。
Oh, great. He's ducking us. I didn't hear you there. Now, does she give it up for you? Do your kids give it up to you? Do they think what you're doing is a waste of time or that you're actually good at what you do? They're not... they don't think much of it.
如果我要谈论我今天做了什么，我最好简明扼要。对。控制在45秒以内。你知道的，我卖了一部电影。奈飞（Netflix）要拍它。这会是一件大事。所以你今天过得怎么样？
And if I'm going to talk about what I did today, I better keep it tight. Right. Keep it to 45 seconds. You know, I sold a movie. Netflix is making it. It's going to be a big thing. And so how was your day?
是的。而如果他们愿意开口，你会花上几个小时听他们讲他们的一天。但你的孩子也像我的孩子那样说话简练吗？非常难。非常难。我现在有个规矩，你来吃晚饭时必须带一个关于某事的轶事。
Yeah. And you would listen for hours about their day if they would be willing to talk about it. But do your kids keep it all tight like mine do? It's very tough. Very tough. I've got this thing now going where you got to come to dinner with an anecdote of something.
哦，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这样。今天发生的事。今天一定发生了什么挺搞笑的事吧，不然就没饭吃？那是后果吗？不。我又不是个怪物，杰森。
Oh, I love that. I like that. Of the day. There must something happen today that was kind of funny. Or no food? Is that the consequence? No. It's not a monster, Jason.
这是在威胁他的孩子吗？我的孩子需要被推一把。杰森，你的多大了？9岁和14岁。对。两个女孩。好吧，你们要进入一段非常奇妙的时期了。
Is that threatening his kids? My kids need a little poke. How old are yours, Jason? Nine and 14. Right. Two girls. Okay. Well, you're coming into some very strange time.
那是威胁他的孩子吗？我的孩子们需要受点刺激。你的多大了，杰森？九岁和十四岁。对。两个女孩。好的。好吧，你们要进入一段非常奇怪的时期了。
I know. It's only going to get harder is what I'm anticipating. You're ahead of me there. It does get harder. Yes? No, it's just different. When they get to be 15, they will be gone. The door will close and they will individuate.
我知道。我预计情况只会越来越难。这方面你比我有远见。确实会变难。是吗？不，只是感觉不同。当他们到了15岁，他们就会离开。房门会关上，他们会开始独立。
Have you heard that word? No. But now I have it. That is what teenagers do to separate. They want to have their own identity separate from the family. And so they close the door to the bedroom and you don't see them for a long time. And it makes sense.
你听过这个词吗？没有。但现在我知道了。这就是青少年独立的方式。他们想要拥有独立于家庭的自我身份。所以他们会关上卧室的门，你很久都见不到他们。这是合情合理的。
I was sort of the same way because like my parents knew me as a kid and now I'm becoming not a kid. And so maybe they might not accept that, but I like who I am now and who I am becoming. And so I don't necessarily want to show to them. I want to show that to the people who know me as that, which are the kids at school and my girlfriend or whatever. Right?
我以前差不多也是这样，因为我父母认识小时候的我，而我现在不再是个孩子了。所以他们可能无法接受这一点，但我喜欢现在的自己和正在成为的自己。因此我未必想向他们展示这一点。我想把它展现给那些以这种身份认识我的人，也就是学校里的孩子们、我的女朋友或者别的什么人。对吧？
I mean, I think that's what's behind it. Yeah. You got to come up with a character to play. Yeah. Who am I going to be in this life? Well, Jason, you were also the meal ticket. So, I mean, let's be real. Your parents would come visit you at Warner Brothers in the math truck
我是说，我觉得这才是背后的原因。对。你得给自己物色一个要扮演的角色。对。我在这生中要成为谁呢？好吧，杰森，你以前也是家里的摇钱树。所以，说实话，你父母会去华纳兄弟的14号摄影棚探班
on stage 14. My parents, when I was growing up, we weren't allowed to talk about movies or TV shows at the table. That was the rule in our house. Really? Why? And they weren't... My parents are nice people because they just thought like,
在14号摄影棚。我小时候，家里是不允许在饭桌上谈论电影或电视节目的。那是我们家的规矩。真的吗？为什么？而且他们并不是……我父母都是好人，因为他们觉得，
no, let's talk about real stuff that's going on in the real world. I could goof around, I could joke around as much as I wanted, but they didn't want to talk about it because they were like, well, that's just make-belief. It's fluff. Yeah. Let's talk about politics. Right?
不，我们要谈论现实世界中正在发生的真实事情。我可以胡闹，可以尽可能地开玩笑，但他们不想谈论这些，因为他们觉得那只是虚构的。都是泡沫。对。我们来谈谈政治吧。对吧？
And so a little bit. Do they know what you do for a living? Yeah. Well, I really, I got, I showed them. Yeah. And that must have gone over well when you said, well, guess what? I'm going right into it.
所以多少有点。他们知道你是靠什么维生的吗？对。好吧，我真的，我让他们见识到了。对。当你对他们说“哈哈，猜怎么着？我这就一头扎进这行了”时，他们当时的反应肯定很精彩吧。
Yeah. They're like, jeez, William. So, Jared, you're obviously one of the most famous people on the planet and always will be. Wow. When you walk around and people stop you, do you like that? Do you hate it? Do you, do people, are you sick of people like,
对。他们会想，天哪，威廉。所以，杰里，你显然是这个星球上最有名的人之一，而且永远都是。哇。当你走在街上，人们拦住你时，你喜欢这样吗？你讨厌吗？你会不会，人们，你会不会厌烦别人说，
hey, you're so funny. Say something funny. I have, as you can imagine, over the years developed a, quite a how to map system of how I deal with people. And how does it go? How does it go? You're at the market and you're going down the aisle. You see someone coming your way.
嘿，你太搞笑了。说个笑话来听听。你可以想象，这些年我摸索出了一套应对人们的地图系统。那是怎么个流程？具体怎么搞？你在超市里走过货架。你看到有人朝你走来。
You see the double take up. They've got you. Tell me a joke. Now you are, you're prepping. How does it go? That's a bad opening line. You have to really, you do get good at judging people really quickly. Yeah, right.
你发现他们认出你了。他们看出来了。给我讲个笑话。现在你，你正在做心理准备。接下来怎么应对？这真是一句糟糕的开场白。你确实得学会迅速判断一个人。是的，没错。
And I do, I do require just a little bit of civility. If you yell at the back of me, that's just impolite, you know. Jerry. You know what I say that's working really well is no thank you. They say, can I have a picture? I go, no, thank you. And they, and sometimes they go, well, I didn't offer him anything. You know who does that?
而且我，我确实需要一点点礼貌。如果你冲着我的背影大喊大叫，那就太没礼貌了，你知道的。杰里。你知道我用得特别好的一句话是什么吗？“不用了，谢谢。”他们说：“能拍张照片吗？”我说：“不用了，谢谢。”然后他们，有时候他们会说：“我又没主动提供什么。”你知道谁也这么干吗？
Amy does that. Amy does that. My ex, she's really good at no thank you. And we're, we're actually, we took, I was telling these guys, we took, I took like seven, 12 year olds to see Dune last night. Oh, wow. And Amy, yeah, it was actually amazing. And Amy and I were waiting outside.
艾米也这样。艾米也这样。我的前妻，她非常擅长说“不用了，谢谢”。而且我们，实际上我们带着，我跟这些人说过，我们带了大约七个12岁的孩子昨晚去看《沙丘》。哦，哇。而且艾米，是的，其实真的很神奇。我和艾米在外面等。
We let them go to this virtual reality thing. And this guy comes up and he, and he starts going, oh, you guys, we got to dig in and she goes, no, thank you. And he, and he had this, he was confused. And then he just turned and he walked away. And I was like, wow, that was really good. I take a picture at any time. Anybody asked me anywhere I go, I always stop and take a picture
我们让他们去玩那个虚拟现实的东西。然后这家伙走过来，他，他开始说：“哦，你们几个，我们得进去看看”，然后她说：“不用了，谢谢。”然后他，他当时整个人很迷茫。接着他转身就走了。当时我就想：“哇，那真的太绝了。”我随时都愿意拍照。不管是谁问我，无论我在哪，我总是停下来拍照，
because without them or nothing. Well, look at Sean. Hey, that's the nicest goddamn guy. He wants another job. Why are you crossing your fingers on camera? Uncross them. Why are you crossing your finger? Now let's talk a tiny bit about cars, please.
因为没有他们就没有我的一切。你看肖恩。嘿，这绝对是个超级大好人。他这是想换工作了吧。你为什么在镜头前把手指交叉？快解开。你为什么要把手指交叉？现在请稍微聊聊汽车吧，好吗？
And specifically about, about car racing. Did you ever think about following Letterman into that passion of like owning a car racing team? No, that's a serious thing. I mean, but think about all the, like, you like Porsches. There's the whole circuit for that, right? Yeah, it's a whole world. I don't have time.
具体谈谈，关于赛车。你有没有想过步莱特曼的后尘，去培养拥有一个赛车队的爱好？不，那可是一件严肃的事。我是说，但想想所有那些，比如你喜欢保时捷。那有一整套赛车圈子，对吧？对，那是一个全新的世界。我没时间。
I don't have the brain that's, I'm busy. I'm, it's really hard to be a standup comedian through these various phases of life. Yeah. Forties in your fifties and your sixties. And what you can and can't say anymore and all that. Yeah. Well, what do you mean by that?
我的脑子没法，我很忙。要在人生的不同阶段一直做单口喜剧演员，真的很难。对。四十几岁、五十几岁和六十几岁。还有你还能说什么、不能说什么，以及诸如此类的事情。对。好吧，你这话是什么意思？
Well, just like there, it seems right. This is like a whole other two hour discussion. Just it seems no comedy. No, get into it. Get canceled, Sean. Hurry up. No, let's talk about it. I've heard other comedians say it's hard to write jokes
嗯，只是好像，没错。这简直可以展开成另外两个小时的讨论。只是感觉没有喜剧了。不，深入聊聊吧。被取消资格吧，肖恩。快点。不，我们来聊聊这个。我听其他喜剧演员说过，现在写段子很难，
that I used to write because I can't say them for a reason A, B or C. And that always exists, there's certain things you could just say at a cocktail party that you can't say, you know, maybe five years or 10 years ago. Right. But comedy is a very self-correcting environment. If the audience senses that you're not into it
因为我以前写的东西现在因为ABC各种原因不能讲了。这种现象一直存在，有些话你在鸡尾酒会上随口就能说，但在五年前或十年前可能就不能说了，你知道的。没错。但喜剧是一个自我纠正能力很强的领域。如果观众觉得你不在状态，
or, you know, nobody laughs at a reputation. You go up in front of 3,000 people. You're either really funny that night or it's silence and it's horrible. Right. So it takes, for me, it takes constant work just so I could say I'm a comedian and if you booked me, the show will be good.
或者，你知道的，没人会为名气买账。你站在三千人面前。那天晚上你要么真的很搞笑，要么全场鸦雀无声，那感觉糟透了。没错。所以对我来说，这需要源源不断的工作，好让我能说自己是个喜剧演员，而且如果你预约了我，演出就会很精彩。
But what you meant more was it's difficult as a human being to go through all the stages of life as a comedian through your 30s and your 40s as you change as a person. Right. That's a lot of work. Yeah. Yeah, it's a lot of work.
但你的意思是，作为一个普通人，在三十多岁和四十多岁时，随着个人心境的转变，经历人生各个阶段作为喜剧演员的心路历程是很艰难的。没错。那要做很多功课。对。是的，那需要做很多功课。
But I'm lucky that I love the work and I'm willing to do it. And I like the simplicity and the independence of it. But if you think about how many comedians that started on The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson are even still out there working. Yeah. It's a pretty short list. You know, it's very hard to sustain
但我很幸运，我热爱这项工作，并且愿意为之付出。我喜欢它的简单和独立。但如果你想想，当年在《今夜秀》和强尼·卡森一起出道的喜剧演员现在还有多少人在坚持。对。那名单可真够短的。你知道的，如果你不坚持下去，
if you don't keep at it. So anyway, to go back to the car thing, I don't do these hobbies. I can't do them. Right. I really love working on staying a good comedian. And part of that, I would assume, is staying super current and talking about and observing the things that are current.
是很难维系下去的。总之，回到汽车的话题，我不搞这些爱好。我玩不转。对。我真的很热爱致力于保持一个优秀的喜剧演员状态。我想，其中一部分工作就是保持高度敏锐，去谈论和观察那些紧跟时代的事物。
And one of those things happens to be this thing that I think Sean was intimating at, which is stuff that is a little tougher to talk about nowadays or that there's more separation between this side of the street and that side of the street, this sensitivity and whatnot. And do you feel, since comedy is such a great way in which to talk about things that are uncomfortable and somewhat taboo, do you maybe see a role for comedy
而其中一件事恰好就是肖恩刚才暗示的那些事，也就是现在更难启齿的话题，或者是街头这一边和那一边之间、这种敏感度等等之间出现更多分歧的事。你是否觉得，既然喜剧是谈论那些不舒服且有些禁忌话题的绝佳方式，你是否觉得喜剧或许能发挥某种作用，
to be one of those things that bridges into a more unified public? I don't think so. I don't like comedy that's about the big obvious things that we all see. Show me something small that I never noticed and blow it way out of proportion. Then I'm laughing. That's a great point. Then I'm laughing.
成为能够架起通往更加团结的公众桥梁的工具之一？我不这么认为。我不喜欢那种只讲我们都看得到的那些宏大、明显事情的喜剧。让我看看那些我从未注意过的小事，并把它无限放大。那样我才会笑。这真是个绝佳的观点。那样我才会笑。
Yeah, I think that you're right. Who was it was saying? Somebody recently was talking about this idea that when was it that all of a sudden that all comedians had to be philosophers? Yeah. And it used to be just about jokes about, that was it. And we've somehow shifted the importance.
对，我觉得你是对的。那是谁说的来着？最近有人在讨论这样一个观点：什么时候开始，所有的喜剧演员突然之间都必须成为哲学家了？对。而过去，喜剧仅仅是关于笑话的，仅此而已。不知怎的，我们改变了它的重要性。
And it's just not that. Not to say that it's not important to make people laugh. You know what I'm saying. Yeah. But when George Carlin would talk about how the government doesn't care about you and these big, it wasn't funny to me. It's not funny. When he would talk about the stuff and the suitcase
事实并非如此。这并不是说让人发笑不重要，你知道我的意思。对。但每当乔治·卡林谈论政府根本不在乎你以及这些宏大的事情时，我并不觉得好笑。这并不好笑。当他谈论那些东西和手提箱，
and some little thing that I didn't notice. It was so funny. Comedians do not change people's opinions. Right. They don't for good or ill. I like John Stuart. I never changed my mind about anything after watching a comedian. Right.
以及某些我没注意到的微小细节时。那可太搞笑了。喜剧演员根本改变不了人们的观点。对。无论好坏，他们都改变不了。我喜欢约翰·斯图尔特。看了喜剧演员的表演后，我从来没有改变过对任何事情的看法。对。
I think people like to hear cultural perspective or even political perspective from comedians because it's more entertaining. Right. But it's not more persuasive. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know about that.
我觉得人们喜欢听喜剧演员表达文化视角甚至政治视角，因为这更有娱乐性。对。但这并不更具说服力。好吧。我不知道，我对此保留意见。
I think that the power of comedy is you can educate people without them knowing it almost. You know. I don't think they care what you think. All right. Sean, why are you, obviously Jerry's right and you're wrong. What are you doing? It might be something to it.
我认为喜剧的力量在于，你几乎可以在不知不觉中启迪人们。你知道的。我认为他们才不在乎你怎么想呢。好吧。肖恩，你为什么——显然杰里是对的，你是错的。你在干什么？这可能也有点道理。
But it's certainly not as much fun. It's not as much fun to be educated by a comedian as it is to hear about someone's insanity. Yeah. That to me is the most calming and liberating feeling when someone reveals their insanity to you. And it's funny. Yeah.
但它绝对没有那么有趣。被一个喜剧演员启迪，远不如听一个人的疯癫言论来得有趣。对我和平复心情、获得解放最有效的时刻，莫过于有人向你展露他们的疯癫。而且这很好笑。对。
Then we have fun. And I think we need that more than the data. Do you feel like you could have done anything else? Not as well. But I could have. Yes. I could have been just a writer. I could have.
那样我们才能玩得开心。我觉得比起数据，我们更需要这个。你觉得你当初还能干点别的吗？不如现在好。但我确实可以。是的。我本来可以只当个作家。我完全可以。
Advertising. I bet you would. You would have been incredible at advertising. I'll bet you. Sort of. I loved advertising because it was short and you had to have, you know, a very compressed idea. And it could be funny.
广告业。我敢打赌你会的。你在广告业绝对能干得风生水起。我敢保证。差不多吧。我热爱广告业，因为它篇幅短，而且你必须得有一个高度凝练的创意。而且它还可以很有趣。
You know, in the 60s, advertising was pretty funny stuff. I love the show Mad Men. Yeah. I thought you were going to do that. When Seinfeld shut down and started doing a bit, did you start doing a bit more for AmEx right around then? I did some AmEx stuff. And I did flirt with starting a small boutique agency.
你知道的，在60年代，广告可是相当有趣的东西。我很喜欢《广告狂人》这部剧。对。我还以为你会去拍那个呢。当《宋飞正传》停播并开始拍短片时，你大概就在那个时候开始为美国运通拍更多广告了吧？我拍了一些美国运通的东西。而且我还动过开一家小型精品代理公司的念头。
Really? Wow. Yeah. That would have been cool. It would have been work. And making commercials is the best too though. Just being an actor in commercials is the best. Making commercials is the best.
真的吗？哇。对。那一定很酷。那可得干活。而且拍广告也是最棒的。仅仅作为广告里的演员就是最棒的。拍广告最棒了。
It's the best schedule. Yeah. Be there. Can you be here by 10 because we got to wrap it too. Yeah. You know? And you're like, okay, and it's one shot. And then you're done.
时间安排最好。对。到场就行。你10点能到吗，因为我们2点前必须收工。对。你知道吗？然后你会想，好吧，一个镜头就搞定。然后你就收工了。
Yeah. We'll be right back. And back to the show. What happens the rest of your day to day? What's a typical weekend for you guys out there? Is it relaxing? Are you going to go out there and with a little notebook and do a little bit of work?
好，我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。你一天的其余时间都怎么过？你们平时典型的周末是什么样的？是放松休息吗？还是会拿个小笔记本出去写点段子？
I already had a, I try and do a morning writing session. I find that more productive. And then I have some meetings about the movie thing. The pop-dart thing, you're not yet rolling cameras, are you? Not yet rolling. Early next year we start rolling. Are you excited about the directing part of it? Or are you thinking, boy, this could be a lot of work?
我已经有了一个，我尽量安排一个早晨的写作时间。我觉得这样效率更高。然后我要开一些关于电影的会。那个“Pop-Tart”的电影，你们还没开始拍摄吧？还没开机。明年初我们就要开机了。你对导演这部分工作感到兴奋吗？还是会想，天哪，这可能会有很多工作要干？
It's a lot of work, which I don't mind work, but I don't really know what I'm doing. And I don't know, that's fun at this point. Who's going to help you though with that? Do you have yourself an adult that's going to surround you with? I have my writer guys. And it'll be funny. It may not look like a real movie, but it'll be funny.
工作量确实很大，我不介意干活，但我其实不知道自己在干什么。而且我不知道，到了这个份上，这反倒挺有意思的。不过谁会帮你呢？你身边有没有配备一个成年人来指导你？我有我的编剧团队。而且这会很有趣。拍出来可能看起来不像一部真正的电影，但它一定很好笑。
Who are your writer guys? We can always cut them out if we don't like them. Spike Ferreston, who wrote The Soup Nazi. I love Spike. I love Spike. And Andy Robin, who wrote a lot of the episodes. And Barry Marta, who invented Ted El Nancy, letters from a nut.
你的编剧团队都有谁？如果我们不喜欢，随时可以把他们踢掉。斯派克·费雷斯顿，他是《汤纳粹》的编剧。我喜欢斯派克。我喜欢斯派克。还有安迪·罗宾，他写了很多集的剧本。还有巴里·马塔，他创作了《泰德和南希》以及《一个疯子的来信》。
First of all, this is not the first Spike mention on the podcast because we were talking about his brother Wally the other day. Oh, yeah. Who's the greatest cue card guy in the history of cue cards. Wally's a great guy. Wally texted me afterwards, by the way. And he was like, thank you and fuck Bateman. Spike is the guy who pushed me into it and said, let's make this,
首先，这并不是这档播客第一次提到斯派克，因为前几天我们还在聊他弟弟沃利呢。哦，对。那是历史上最厉害的提词卡大师。沃利是个好人。顺便说一句，沃利事后还给我发了短信。他说：“谢谢你，去他的贝特曼。”斯派克就是那个把我推上这条路、说“我们把这个拍成电影吧”的人，
because he has a little production company. That makes sense. Let's do this as a movie. And I just thought it was ridiculous, but it came out good. Who are the people who make you laugh the most? And by the way, it doesn't need to be touring comedians or standups. Like who are the people that Americans might not know? Like guys like Spike.
因为他有一家小型制作公司。这就说得通了。我们把这个拍成电影吧。我当时觉得这太荒谬了，但拍出来效果确实不错。哪些人最能让你开怀大笑？顺便说一句，这不一定非得是巡演喜剧演员或单口相声演员。比如有哪些是美国人可能不太了解的人？就像斯派克这样的人。
I don't know if there's a guy I watch a lot. I only met him one time named Pablo Francisco. You ever heard of this guy? No. No, is he hilarious? He's a crazy, crazy guy. I'm going to write it down. And I watch his YouTube stuff a lot.
我不知道有没有哪个人是我经常看的。我只见过他一次，叫巴勃罗·弗朗西斯科。你听说过这个人吗？没有。没有，他很搞笑吗？他是个极其疯狂的人。我要把他的名字记下来。我经常看他在YouTube上的视频。
And I watch a lot of old Bernie Mac on YouTube. He's so funny. But Pablo Francisco is my idea of a comedian. He's just an insane guy. I can't really describe him, but maybe somebody will check him out after this. I'm writing him down right now. I'm going to check him out.
而且我在YouTube上看了很多伯尼·麦克的旧视频。他太搞笑了。但巴勃罗·弗朗西斯科才是我心目中的喜剧演员。他简直是个疯子。我真的无法形容他，但也许有人听了节目后会去搜来看看。我正在把他的名字记下来。我要去搜来看看。
So Pablo Francisco. Yeah. Check him out on YouTube. Bernie Mac. Bernie Mac. I love Sebastian Menescalco. I love Chris Rock. Yeah.
所以是巴勃罗·弗朗西斯科。对。去YouTube上搜他。伯尼·麦克。伯尼·麦克。我很喜欢塞巴斯蒂安·马尼斯科。我很喜欢克里斯·洛克。对。
Chris Rock. He is so good. My daughter can make me laugh anytime she wants. He's the only person I know that can just, anytime she wants, she can make me laugh. Are they interested in how a joke is, works and constructed and all that? She has become interested recently.
克里斯·洛克。他太优秀了。我女儿随时都能把我逗笑。她是我认识的唯一一个能随时随地把我逗笑的人。他们对笑话是如何运作、如何构建这些感兴趣吗？她最近开始感兴趣了。
Yeah. And anybody that will listen to me, explain why that's funny. And she's getting interested. Does she want to do that? How old is she? She's 20. She's 20.
对。只要有人愿意听我解释为什么这个好笑，她就会听。而且她现在越来越感兴趣了。她想走这条路吗？她多大了？她20岁。她20岁。
Yeah. And so she is in college now or is she waiting? She's in college. She's an English major. And comedy is like that dandelion that breaks through the sidewalk. It's like, you can't make it happen. If it wants to do that, it's going to do that.
对，所以她现在上大学了，还是在待业？她在上大学。她主修英语。喜剧就像那朵破土而出的蒲公英。它顺其自然，你强求不来。如果它想那样发展，它就会那样发展。
Yeah. So my 11-year-old is a really funny, really funny kid. And Amy and I have gone out of our way to be like, we don't want to be showbiz parents. We're not encouraging any sort of direction. In fact, if anything, we're like, whatever. If there's no way around it, this kid is really funny.
对，所以我那个11岁的孩子是个非常搞笑、非常搞笑的小家伙。艾米和我一直刻意保持低调，心想我们不想当娱乐圈的父母。我们不鼓励任何特定方向的发展。事实上，如果说有什么不同的话，我们的态度是：随其自然吧。话虽如此，这孩子确实非常有天赋。
Yeah. Like you said. He makes me laugh. His timing is so shocking sometimes. Wow. That we can't... It's genetic. It is genetic.
对，就像你说的。他能把我逗笑。他的时机把握有时简直惊艳。哇，让我们不得不……这绝对是基因。这绝对是基因。
I guess. And there's nothing you can do about it. There's nothing you can do? It takes all the work off of you. You can encourage and point and direct maybe. If she wants to do that, you could probably point her in the right direction, perhaps. But you can't help.
我猜是的。对此你无可奈何。你真的无能为力吗？这省去了你所有的麻烦。你或许可以给予鼓励、指点和引导。如果她想走这条路，你可能可以为她指明正确的方向，也许吧。但你帮不上忙。
You can't help. You can't say, I know someone and I could get you in here. I don't think that's healthy. No, I agree. Well, the first step is helpful. You can at least get her in the door, perhaps, and then what she does with her access and opportunities. You know what?
你帮不上忙。你不能说：“我认识某个人，我可以把你弄进这个圈子。”我觉得那样不健康。不，我同意。好吧，迈出第一步还是有帮助的。你至少可以帮她敲开大门，至于她如何利用这些途径和机会，那就另当别论了。你知道吗？
It's kind of a nightmare. Can you imagine having this last name, and now you want people to believe you have time? I mean, it's a nightmare. The first step, no one's going to begrudge you the first one. You can pull a Warren Buffett and not leave any of your money to them, too. I think he left them like 50 million,
这简直是一场噩梦。你能想象顶着这个姓氏，然后你还想让别人相信你有实力吗？我是说，这简直是个噩梦。至于第一步，没人会嫉妒你迈出第一步。你也可以学沃伦·巴菲特，不给他们留任何遗产。我想他好像留给他们大约5000万，
and he thought that was like really conservative. Oh, really? I think so. Yeah. He definitely left them something. How do you do that? How do you live on 50 million? Yeah.
而且他觉得这已经非常保守了。哦，真的吗？我想是的。是的，他确实给他们留了点东西。你怎么能做到那样？怎么能靠5000万过活？对。
I remember a guy, somebody told me a story about a guy that we knew a mutual friend, and he got a payout from some company of like 90 million dollars, and he turned to my friend and he said, my friend goes, wow, 90 million dollars. He goes, I know it takes some people a lifetime to make that kind of money. Now, when your daughter makes you laugh, do you know why she's making you laugh?
我记得有人跟我讲过一个故事，关于一个我们认识的人，一个共同的朋友，他从某家公司拿到了大约9000万美元的分红，他转向我的朋友说，我朋友说：“哇，9000万美元。”他说：“我知道，有些人一辈子也赚不到这种钱。”话说回来，当你的女儿把你逗笑时，你知道她为什么能逗笑你吗？
Is it sarcasm? Is it irony? Is it timing? Yeah, very sarcastic. And you don't know what they're picking up from you around the house. They're listening in on you. They're always noticing something that you're not aware of.
是讽刺吗？是反讽吗？是时机把握吗？对，非常讽刺。而且你根本不知道他们从你在屋里的言行中都学到了什么。他们在偷听你们说话。他们总能注意到一些你根本没意识到的小细节。
Right. Right. And that's just the fun. That's the fun of it, you know. What about your other kids? You know what they want to do yet? No, one of them is into music. The other's into sports.
没错。对。这就是乐趣所在，你知道的。你的其他孩子呢？你知道他们想做什么吗？没有，其中一个喜欢音乐。另一个喜欢体育。
Yeah. You know, as long as they get a whole, just get a bite on something, and I'm happy, anything. You're not coaching teams, are you? No. No. Ever thought about it? I know.
对，只要他们能对某样东西产生热情，我就高兴，什么都行。你没有在当球队教练吧？没有。没有。从来没想过吗？我知道。
I wish I knew enough about baseball because I love it so much to coach it, because I would do that if I could, but I couldn't. Wait, hang on. What do you not know about baseball? Wait, let me just tell you this. As a Canadian, I know probably the least amount about baseball growing up. I never played organized baseball, and I coached Little League
我希望我对棒球有足够的了解——因为我太爱它了——可以去当教练，因为如果可以的话我肯定会去，但我实在不懂。等等，等一下。你对棒球有什么不懂的？等等，我这么跟你说吧。作为一个加拿大人，我成长过程中对棒球的了解大概是最少的。我从来没打过有组织的棒球联赛，但我却当了五年少棒联盟的教练。
for five years. Wow. I will say there were those moments where I was like, okay, on the next one, I think you guys should run or not, or not run. There's only probably three or four rules. I'll bet you or I, Jerry, don't really fully understand. Probably is around the infield fly rule, something in there, box and things like that.
哇。我得说，确实有那么几个时刻，我在想：“好吧，接下来这个球，我觉得你们应该跑垒，或者不跑，或者别跑。”棒球其实大概只有三四条规则。我敢打赌你和我，杰里，其实都并没有完全搞懂。大概就是内野飞球规则之类的，里面有些东西，还有封垒规则之类的。
But like, do you really think you don't know enough about baseball to coach Little League team? I mean, I don't want to keep your shoulder in, you know, make sure don't lift your leg up when you, before you swing. I don't know what you're supposed to do. You know, it's not about that for Little League. That's too late. They're too old.
但话说回来，你真的觉得你对棒球的了解不够去当少棒联盟的教练吗？我是说，我可不想管你的肩膀，你知道的，确保你挥棒前别把腿抬太高。我根本不知道你该做什么。你知道的，少棒联盟不讲究那个。那太晚了。他们太大了。
Get them back into it, Jerry. Come on, think about it. Just say you'll think about it. I'll think about it. So comedians and cars getting coffee, are you still doing that? Is that done? No, that's, I think I'm going to put that volume on the shelf.
重新让他们加入进来吧，杰里。拜托，考虑一下。哪怕说你会考虑一下也行。我会考虑的。那么，喜剧演员乘车去买咖啡，你还在拍吗？那个节目结束了吗？不，那个，我想我要把那一卷收起来放进书架了。
That was a great show. I love it. Oh, thank you very much. It was a lot of fun, and I got to meet and a lot of those people that I had not met, we're friends now. And it's amazing what two hours with somebody, your friends forever after that. Yeah, yeah.
那是个很棒的节目。我很喜欢。哦，非常感谢。那真的非常有趣，而且我结识了许多以前没见过的人，现在我们都成朋友了。真的很神奇，跟一个人呆上两个小时，之后你们就成了永远的朋友。对，对。
It was really great. Like this, like doing this. That's what I was going to say. We're so stunned that people like yourself, heroes of ours, will sit and talk with us for an hour. I just, I dork out. I really, it's such a treat. I can say that Jason is, this is, Sean, will you attest to
真的很棒。就像这样，就像做这个节目一样。我正要这么说。我们太震惊了，像你这样的人，我们的偶像，竟然愿意坐下来跟我们聊上一小时。我简直，我都变成狂热粉丝了。真的，这简直是一种巨大的享受。我可以这么说，杰森今天，肖恩，你来作证，
this? Jason is legitimately starstruck today. He's very nervous. Absolutely. He's talking more than usual. Yeah, you're kind of high pitched a little bit. Love you, Jerry. Yeah.
杰森今天绝对是见到偶像了。他非常紧张。千真万确。他比平时话多多了。对，你的声音听起来有点尖。爱你，杰里。对。
Thank you. Does any part of you, did any part of you enjoy that in being on the other side of an interview process and asking the questions in that, on that show? Yeah, because I always felt like a really good interview becomes an intense conversation. Right. As opposed to reading a series of questions.
谢谢。你身上有没有哪怕一点点，有没有哪怕一点点喜欢这种感觉——站在采访流程的另一边，在那个节目里充当提问的人？对，因为我一直觉得，一场真正精彩的采访会变成一场深入的对话。没错。而不是照本宣科地念一串问题。
Yeah. Sean. Something someone says, you pick up on something in that and want to go further down. The reason I asked about the interview thing is because I always wondered the next question, which would be, would you ever want to do a podcast? Is that like a, a desire of yours to go, oh, did everybody's
对。肖恩。别人说的某句话，你会抓住其中的某个点，然后想要深入探讨下去。我之所以问采访的事，是因为我一直很好奇接下来这个问题，那就是：你有没有想过做一档播客？这算不算是你的愿望，让你觉得，“哦，是不是所有人都在涉足这个领域？”那些问题到底是什么鬼？
kind of delving into this world? What the heck are the questions? Well, that was kind of my idea of a podcast was, can you just give me the good 11 minutes of that? Right. Right. And so that's what comedians and cars was, but the editing was, was very intense.
好吧，我心目中的播客差不多就是：你能不能直接给我那精彩的11分钟？没错。没错。这就是《喜剧演员乘车去买咖啡》的模式，但后期的剪辑工作非常繁重。
And this actually to me is, you know, Colin Quinn and I have these, we have breakfast like, you know, three times a week and because he's one of the few comedians I know that sits down and tries to grind out material the way I do. And if you, if you spend a lot of your life as a writer, you want to talk to other writers about how difficult it is and how discouraging it is. And this is, I'm enjoying this and I'm very happy that I'm
而且这对我来说其实，你知道的，科林·奎因和我经常这样，我们一周大概吃三次早餐，因为他是为数不多的几个我认识的、会像我一样坐下来苦思冥想打磨段子的喜剧演员。如果你把人生的大部分时间花在写作上，你会想和同行交流这种创作有多难、有多令人沮丧。而现在，我很享受这个过程，我也很高兴我正在做这件事，
doing it, but it's really the same mental energy that it would go into a writing session. Right. For me to find the words or the thought or the, the path for this idea, where do you take it? And I know comedians, they all have podcasts. They all do podcasts. If I was coaching or teaching young comics, I would say never,
但它消耗的心理能量实际上跟写作是一样的。没错。对我来说，去找寻词句、思绪，或是这个创意的脉络，你要把它带往何处？我知道喜剧演员，他们都有播客。他们所有人都在做播客。如果我在指导或教授年轻的喜剧演员，我会告诉他们：永远、永远不要去做播客。
ever do a podcast. Spend that time working on your idea that you're going to do that night. Right. Go out tonight with something that you've figured out about that idea. Struggle with the idea. I, you know, is part of the struggle.
把那些时间花在打磨你当晚要表演的创意上。没错。今晚带着你对那个创意琢磨出来的成果登台。去和这个创意死磕。我，你知道的，这也是死磕的一部分。
I asked because this is one of the challenges I love about directing and I'll never, ever master it. I don't doubt anybody ever can. Here we go. No, no, but at least three minute long question. Go ahead. Here is a short one. Is it about funneling a bunch of people into one narrow thought
我之所以这么问，是因为这是我非常热爱导演工作的原因之一，而且我永远、永远也无法完全精通它。我不认为任何人能做到。来吧。不，不，但至少是个长达三分钟的问题。请继续。这是一个简短的问题。这算不算是把一大群人的思绪引导到一个狭隘的观点里，
when you're trying to get them? Have you ever noticed why or ever noticed this and you try to build a picture for them and it gets everybody comes down the same channel into, into what, into the, the, the punchline finally. Well, it's, it's the, it's the success of the clarity. Yeah. You know, for example, if you say, do you ever notice you've
当你试图吸引他们的时候？你有没有注意到为什么，或者有没有注意到这一点，然后你试着为他们勾勒出一幅画面，结果所有人顺着同一条通道走进来，走进了什么，最后走进了——包袱里。好吧，这，这是清晰度带来的成功。对。你知道的，举个例子，如果你说：“你们有没有注意到……”
lost them already. Okay. Just that in to an idea is a turnoff to an audience. They don't want to hear that. So now let's find another way, a better way to bring this subject up. Right. Maybe a funny way.
你已经把他们听众给赶跑了。好吧。仅仅以这种方式切入一个创意，对观众来说就是一种排斥。他们不想听这个。所以现在我们要寻找另一种、更好的方式来引出这个话题。没错。也许用一种有趣的方式。
Right. Um, for example, just to pick something. I see the Chinese are hanging in there with the chopsticks. I'm sure they've seen the four. Okay. So that's, so that's that now that takes time. That takes time. I don't want to say, Hey, you ever notice that we use forks and
没错。嗯，举个例子，随便挑一个。我发现中国人到现在还在坚持用筷子。我相信他们肯定看过叉子。好了。所以，所以就是这样，但这需要时间。这需要时间。我不想说：“嘿，你们有没有发现我们用叉子，而”
the Chinese use chopsticks. Point taken. Point taken. Point taken. Now, but no, but now let's take that example. That's what writing is. That's what writing is. Hang on.
“中国人用筷子。”领会意图了。领会意图了。领会意图了。好了，但是不，现在我们拿这个例子来说明。这就是写作。这就是写作。等一下。
Make it unfunny, Jason. Go ahead. Break it down. What audiences are bored stiff sitting there and you're, and you have to unbore them and it's a, it's a big job. The funniest part is they're hanging in there. Yeah. That's the funniest part of that job.
把它弄得一点都不好笑吧，杰森。来吧。拆解一下。观众坐在那里面如死灰，而你必须把他们从这种无聊中拯救出来，这是一项艰巨的任务。最搞笑的部分是他们还在坚持用筷子。对。那段话里最搞笑的就是这个。
The audience purifies the comedy context. You don't have to worry that someone is saying something that offends a certain group because if it's really offensive, guess who you're going to lose first, the people right in front of you, even though you have paid to see you, if they don't like what you're doing, you'll know real quick. Right. And so you don't have to worry about policing comedians.
观众会净化喜剧的语境。你根本不用担心有人会说出冒犯某个群体的话，因为如果真的具有冒犯性，你猜你会最先失去谁？就是坐在你面前的那些人，尽管他们花钱来看你的演出，但如果他们不喜欢你的表演，你很快就会知道的。没错。所以你根本不用去管束喜剧演员。
We are the most policed people there are. The most judged human in the culture is the comedian. We get a grade every 11 seconds. Instantaneously. Yeah. Yeah. That's true. That's a good point.
我们才是受管束最多的人。文化中受审判最多的人就是喜剧演员。我们每隔11秒就会得到一次评分。即时的。对。对。确实如此。这话说得太对了。
And even when you're doing like a sitcom, you have a live audience there to let you know whether it's working, whether it's not. Yeah. Thank God. Thank God. That really shaped, that's what shapes the material. The material you're seeing is the result of the past 50 crowds
甚至当你在拍情景喜剧时，现场也会有观众让你知道这管不管用，行不行。对。谢天谢地。谢天谢地。正是这个塑造了素材。你看到的素材，是我面对过去50场观众的成果。
I faced. This is what they liked. Right. Yeah. And then you, that's how you, that's how you refine it. That's so cool. Well, watch this, watch this segue. We like you, Jerry, and we like this conversation.
他们喜欢这个。没错。对，然后你，这就是你打磨它的方式。太酷了。好吧，看这个，看这个过渡。我们喜欢你，杰里，我们也喜欢这次对话。
Yeah. And you please like the rest of your Saturday. Say hi to your family. Please. Thank you guys. It's a great show. Thank you for coming on. Thank you for having me.
对，请好好享受你周末剩下的时间。代我向你家人问好。拜托了。谢谢你们。这节目太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你们让我来。
We love you. We miss you. We want more. Jerry, you're so hilarious. So, so consistently funny. Such a fan. I love it. Oh my God.
我们爱你。我们想念你。我们还想看更多。杰里，你太搞笑了。太，太始终如一地好笑了。我是你的超级粉丝。我太喜欢了。天哪。
Thank you. I'll see you at Bloomingdale's. Thank you, Jerry. Very, very, very much. All right, guys. Thank you. All right, Paul. Bye.
谢谢。回头在布鲁明戴尔百货见。非常、非常、非常感谢你，杰里。好了，各位。谢谢。好的，保罗。再见。
All right. Bye. All right. So now what really did I see nervous? I mean, you didn't stop talking that entire podcast. Well, but I wanted to make, he's my guest. No, you want to be friends with him. You want to be friends with him.
好的。再见。好吧，那么现在我到底哪里显得紧张了？我是说，你在整个播客录制过程中根本就没停过嘴。好吧，但我只是想，他是我的嘉宾。不，你是想跟他套近乎。你就是想跟他交朋友。
Well, I will take him as a friend. It was obvious. Absolutely. I will take him as a friend. Did you know him from before, Jay? He liked you a lot, though. I can tell. He liked you.
好吧，我愿意把他当朋友。明摆着的事。绝对的。我愿意交他这个朋友。你以前就认识他吗，杰伊？不过他确实挺喜欢你的。我看得出来。他挺喜欢你的。
Bullshit. No, he liked you. I don't think I've ever, I don't think I've ever met Jerry. I've never met him. That was the first time I've ever met him. You haven't? No. You said, well, you've met him, right?
少来。不，他喜欢你。我觉得我以前，我觉得我从来没见过杰里。我从来没见过他。那是我们第一次见面。你没见过？没有。你之前说过，你们见过的吧？
I've met him a bunch of times. He's friends, he's old friends with Chuck Martino. Chuck Martin. And then I did this. We asked him to do this benefit in Toronto. Right. We covered that. Two years ago, the hospital benefit now called Michael
我跟他在一块儿见过好多次。他和查克·马蒂诺是老朋友。查克·马丁。然后我做了这个。我们请他在多伦多做一场慈善演出。对。我们聊过这个。两年前那个医院的慈善晚会，现在叫迈克尔
Garan Hospital in Toronto, which I'm still associated with. Oh, nice plan. Okay. Still associated. What's the hospital? Where can people donate? Where can people donate? I did a little video for you for that.
加兰医院，在多伦多，我现在仍然跟他们有合作。哦，好计划。好吧。还在合作。那是哪家医院？大家可以去哪里捐款？大家可以去哪里捐款？我当时还为你录了个小视频呢。
You did a video for me. Yeah. And Jason did not. I did not. Remember, I asked you to do it and you did not. I don't like charity. I know. And so anyway, so it's a hospital.
你为我录了个视频。对，而杰森没有。我没有。记住，我当时叫你录，而你拒绝了。我不喜欢慈善。我知道。不管怎样，总之是一家医院。
It's like a plug for a hospital. So, you know, in Canada, by the way, where it's universal, they're not even, you don't even get, you have to, you know what I mean? It's not owned by some corporations. So nice, Jay. Nice to meet the real Jason finally after, after over a year of doing the podcast.
这就像是给医院打广告。所以，你知道的，在加拿大，顺便说一句，那里实行全民医保，他们甚至不属于，你懂我的意思吧？它不是被什么大公司垄断的。很高兴认识你，杰伊。在做了一年多播客之后，终于见到了真正的杰森。
Here he is. Anyway, so Jerry came up and he did, he was such a fucking rockstar. He came up and he took photos with everybody and he did everything. And then he did, he didn't do an hour. I think he did close to 90 minutes straight through. He absolutely crushed the place and walked out and like just
他就在这儿。不管怎样，当时杰里来了，他简直就像个该死的摇滚巨星。他来了以后跟每个人都合影，什么都照办。然后他表演了，他可不止演了一个小时。我觉得他差不多连演了90分钟没停。他直接把全场给炸翻了，然后走下台，就像
like, okay. Like, like as if it was nothing like, and we're in awe. And then I had to come out. I had to introduce him. I did like, I did like five minutes actually, which I wrote, which is, you know, I'm not a standup, but... No, but you're good. You're a very good host.
就好像那根本不算什么一样，而我们在旁边叹为观止。然后轮到我登台了。我得去介绍他。我其实讲了差不多五分钟，我自己写的稿子，你知道的，我不是个单口喜剧演员，但是……不，但你很棒。你是个非常优秀的主持人。
Thank you. You're good with a mic and a spotlight. Thank you. I'm terrible at that. And thank you. I think it's being a standup is such a different, God, the respect for standups and running jokes is just off the charts.
谢谢。你很擅长掌控麦克风和聚光灯。谢谢。我在这方面太差劲了。不过谢谢。我觉得当单口喜剧演员真的是一种完全不同的体验，天哪，对单口喜剧演员以及那些连贯笑话的敬佩简直爆表了。
And then anyway, and then he walked away and he killed. And then I had to kind of come up and sort of close out. And I'm like, well, this is terrible, you know. That was, that was big. That was big. And we had Jerry Seinfeld, y'all. Jerry Seinfeld. And he was the first standup in my buddies.
然后不管怎样，他下台后全场爆笑。接着我得上去收尾，当时我就想：“好吧，这太糟糕了，你知道的。”那场面，那场面太盛大了。我们请到了杰里·塞芬特，各位！杰里·塞芬特。他是我追过的第一个单口喜剧演员。
Scotty Bear and John Monteith bought me tickets to go see him live and it was such a thrill. And of course he was hysterical. He delivered every time you see him on Letterman or the Tonight Show. Always funny. Every time he delivered. Every time.
斯科蒂·贝尔和约翰·蒙蒂思买票带我去现场看他的演出，那真是一次巨大的震撼。当然，他超级搞笑。无论你是在莱特曼秀还是今夜秀上看到他，他每一次都表现出色。总是那么搞笑。每一次都发挥完美。
Always funny. Yeah. Sean, I gotta say, like if you were going to do, if you had a magazine that was all about, there was like a tiger magazine on the cover every week, you'd have a tiger, right? Yeah, sure. And if you had a thing that was a magazine was about snakes every week, every week on the cover, you'd have a snake.
总是这么搞笑。对。肖恩，我得说，如果你要做，如果你办了一本杂志，每期封面都有一只老虎，那你每期都会放一只老虎，对吧？对，当然。如果你办了一本杂志，每期都关于蛇，每期封面都有一条蛇。
An elephant. A snake. Sure. A snake. Sure. And if you had a magazine that was about a buffalo, you'd always have a buffalo. Oh no.
一头大象。一条蛇。当然。一条蛇。当然。如果你办了一本杂志，内容是关于水牛的，你肯定每次都放一只水牛。哦，不。
You could also have a bison. Bison. Bison. Bison. Bison. Do you worked hard for it? We're going to give it to you. Smart.
你也可以放一头美洲野牛。野牛。野牛。野牛。野牛。你为它付出了努力。我们这就把它交给你。聪明。
Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart. Last. Smart.
榜单。聪明。榜单。聪明。榜单。聪明。榜单。
SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbicó. Smart. Last. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondery Plus in Apple Podcasts.
《聪明榜单》由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔和本尼特·巴尔比科100%有机手工打造。聪明。榜单。我们的下一期节目将在两周后发布，你可以在任何收听播客的地方听到它，或者你也可以现在就在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts上的Wondery Plus来提前收听无广告版。
Or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或 Wondery 应用程序。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。